I'm at the University of Sydney where I
studied and received my Bachelor of
Education degree I'm helping out with a
program called compass which is run by
the University for high school students
and you can read more details about it
in at their website if you're curious
it's been a strange mix of feelings
being on campus though I haven't been
back to uni since I graduated there's a
part of me that feels really at home
here
walking among the buildings that make
you feel a bit like you're at Hogwarts
I suppose that isn't surprising better I
spent four years of my life here and I
always came to uni five days a week but
there's another part of me that feels
very disoriented and confused being here
and the campus itself looks very
different now there was when I was a
student and walking from railway Square
to Victoria Park
I noticed quite a few old buildings been
torn down new ones had either replaced
them or were in the midst of
construction crossing the footbridge
from Wentworth over City Road is bizarre
because it goes in a different direction
now than before and the fancy law
building on Eastern Avenue it was
literally just a huge hole in the ground
during my final year of study but it's
not mainly the physical aspects of the
university that are giving me this
cognitive disconnect I walked past the
front lawn just now and saw a bunch of
students lounging around on the grass
and I figure they must be on a two or
three hour break or something like that
back in the day I had quite a few of
those because I attended math lectures
which traditionally were held at 8:00
a.m. and finished at 9:00 and then I'd
have to wait around till 11 or 12 when
my first education class was on so I
remember somewhere in the back of my
mind what it was like to have breaks
like that but now that I've been a
full-time worker and also a parent for a
number of years now it just seems weird
for me to look at people sitting around
doing nothing for such long stretches of
time seeing those students brought back
a lot of memories but also let me think
of a few things I wanted to say so here
from this perspective is someone young
enough to remember uni but old enough to
see it with some objectivity are three
thoughts on University students and time
firstly unis students use your time
wisely this is a very special and
limited chapter of life so you don't
want to waste it I don't want to
caricature or unisons as lazy people I
remember my time at university has been
a busy they were definitely way more
full than my days at high school but the
plain fact of the matter is no one the
possible exception of retirees has the
sheer quantity of disposable time that
unist in tap now most you knees have two
semesters that are 13 weeks long which
is 26 weeks where you're obliged to turn
to classes and sit assessments and so on
that means you have 50% of the year
where you can literally do whatever you
like now I know that's something of an
exaggeration because people have
responsibilities to part-time jobs and
other things like that but it's not that
far from the truth so the question for
you is what will you do with all those
hundreds of hours will you sleep study
work travel read learn an instrument
party volunteer hang with friends
whatever you do make sure it's something
you can look back at from the vantage
point of someone working 9:00 to 5:00
every day with just four weeks of annual
leave year from respective of someone
who no longer has that same kind of
disposable time make sure you can look
back from that perspective and say I'm
glad I made those choices in other words
spend your time wisely by the way please
don't get me wrong when you enter
full-time work it's not like they lock
you in a prison or something workers
have a very different kind of freedom to
uni students but that's a topic for
another day and another video so how do
you know if you're spending your time
wisely or not well that leads me to the
second thing I wanted to say which is
uni students spend your time
purposefully think long and hard and
work out what the purpose of your time
at university is and the most obvious
answer that question is it's a stepping
stone to full-time work or fair enough
but there's so much more to unit and
vocational training and to be honest in
most jobs these days including mine the
lion's share of what you need to know
about work will be learned at work not
unit basically you need to be able to
answer the question what am I going to
this place for why spend three or four
or five or more years doing University
what's the purpose that's going to make
all those hundreds of hours traveling
and those thousands of dollars in debt
all worthwhile is it to please your
parents form new relationships challenge
your own view
of the world once you establish that
then you can decide the ways to spend
your time that will be in accordance
with those goals so University students
spend your time wisely spend your time
purposefully and lastly spend your time
thankfully it's a truism of human
experience but no matter what we're
doing our hearts easily gravitate toward
and facile on the hard and frustrating
things in our present situation no
matter what that situation might be
that's what us humans are like it takes
effort to be grateful for things but
whinging and complaining come naturally
to us it doesn't matter how good your
circumstances are or how long you've
been looking forward to them
it only takes a very short amount of
time to discover and dwell on the things
that annoy you I mean some of us spent
our entire HSC year looking forward to
its end and anticipating University and
everything that will be awesome about it
and then we got there and we're all like
oh my timetable is awful the coffee is
so expensive you know my lecture makes
me sleepy I had to pull an all-nighter
because I was finishing those four
assignments that were all due at the
same time and I hate listening too noisy
high school students on public transport
so that's always say and that's how we
feel and we let the negatives dominate
our experience but this is just classic
firstworldproblems you know there are
people in the world who would die for a
primary education and here we are
complaining about receiving a tertiary
education so just stop and remember what
a privilege it is to be able to go to
university remember all the benefits
that we take for granted and that can
only come up come through those with
university experiences and
qualifications remember that you live in
a society that recognizes the worth of
educating its young adults rather than
putting them straight into the unskilled
workforce and is therefore willing to
loan you any students billions of
taxpayer dollars in order to make
widespread higher education a viable
alternative even to those without a cent
to be a name remember it and be grateful
for it spend your time wisely spend your
time purposefully and spend your time
thankfully
went regret it